you started and did a little bit of a
whirlwind overview of how you get 35 000
X speed up or more over python
um Jeremy Howard did a really great
presentation about sort of the basic
like look at the code here's how you get
the speed up like you said that's
something we could uh probably
developers can do for their own code to
see how you can get these gigantic
Speedos but can you maybe speak to the
machine learning task in general how do
you how do you make some of this code
fast and specifics like what would you
say is the main bottleneck
uh for uh machine learning tasks so are
we talking about uh matte Mall matrix
multiplication how do you make that fast
so I mean if you just look at the python
problem right you can say how do I make
python faster
there's been a lot of people that have
been working on the okay how to make
python 2x faster 10x faster or something
like that right and there's been a ton
of projects in that van right Mojo
started from the what can the hardware
do
like what is the limited physics yeah
what is the speed of light what is it
like how fast can the sun go and then
how do I express that yeah right and so
it wasn't well it wasn't anchored
relatively on make python a little bit
faster it's saying cool I know what the
hardware can do let's unlock that right
now when you when you just say how how
gutsy that is to be in the meeting and
as opposed to trying to see how do we
get the Improvement it's like what can
the physics do
I mean maybe I'm a special kind of nerd
but you look at that what is the limit
of physics how fast can these things go
right
when you start looking at that typically
it ends up being a memory problem right
and so today uh particularly with these
specialized accelerators the problem is
that you can do a lot of math within
them but you get bottleneck sending data
back and forth to memory whether it be
local memory or distant memory or disk
or whatever it is and and that that
bottleneck particularly is the training
sizes get large as you start doing tons
of inferences all over the place like
that becomes a huge bottleneck for
people right
so again what happened is we went
through a phase of many years where
people took the special case and hand
tuned it and tweaked it and tricked it
out and they knew exactly how the
hardware worked and they knew the model
and they made it they made it fast
didn't generalize
so you can make you know resident 50 or
some or Alex net or something Inception
V1 like you can you can do that right
because the models are small they fit in
your head right but as the models get
bigger more complicated as the machines
get more complicated it stops working
right and so this is where things like
kernel Fusion come in so what is Chrono
Fusion this is this idea of saying let's
avoid going to memory and let's do that
by building a new hybrid kernel and a
numerical algorithm that actually keeps
things in the accelerator instead of
having to write all the way out to
memory right what's happened with with
these accelerators now you get multiple
levels of memory like in a GPU for
example you'll have Global memory and
local memory and like all these things
um if you zoom way into how Hardware
works the register file is actually a
memory
so the registers are like an L zero
cache and so a lot of taking advantage
of the hardware ends up being fully
utilizing the full power
in all of its capability and this has a
number of problems right one of which is
again the complexity of disaster right
there's too much Hardware even if you
just say let's look at the chips from
one line of vendor like apple or Intel
or whatever it is
each version of the chip comes out with
new features and they change things so
that it takes more time or less time to
do different things and you can't
rewrite all the software whenever a new
chip comes out right and so this is
where you need a much more scalable
approach and this is what Mojo and what
the modular stack provides is it
provides this infrastructure in the
system for factoring all this complexity
and then allowing people to express
algorithms you talk about Auto tuning
for example Express algorithms in a more
portable way so that when a new chip
comes out you have to you don't have to
rewrite it all
so to me like you know I kind of joke
like what is a compiler well there's
many ways to explain that you convert
thing a into thing B and you convert
source code to machine code like you can
talk about many many things that
compilers do but to me it's about a bag
of tricks it's about a system and a
framework that you can hang
complexity it's a system that can then
generalize and it can work on problems
that are bigger than fit in one human's
head right and so what that means what a
good stack and what the modular stack
provides is the ability to walk up to it
with a new problem and it'll generally
work quite well
and that's something a lot of machine
learning infrastructure and tools and
Technologies don't have typical state of
the art today as you walk up
particularly if you're deploying if you
walk up with a new model you try to push
it through the converter the converter
crashes
crazy the state of ml tooling today is
not anything that a c programmer would
ever accept right and it's always been
this kind of flaky set of tooling that's
never been integrated well and it's been
never worked together and because it's
not designed together it's built by
different teams it's built by different
Hardware vendors it's built by different
systems it's built by different internet
companies they're trying to solve their
their problems right and so that means
that we get this fragmented terrible
mess of complexity
so I mean the specifics of Emily Jeremy
showed this uh there's the vectorize
function which I guess is
uh built in to the uh into mojo
vectorized as he showed is built into
the library into the library instead of
the library
um vectorized paralyze yeah which
vectorizes more low-level paralyzes
higher level there's the tiling thing
which is how he demonstrated the um
auto-tune I think so so think of think
about this in like levels hierarchical
levels of abstraction right and so it at
the very if you zoom all the way into a
compute problem you have one floating
Point number right and so then you say
okay I want to be I can do things one at
a time in an interpreter
it's pretty slow right so I can get to
doing one one at a time in a compiler I
can see that I can get to doing four or
eight or Sixteen at a time with vectors
that's called vectorization
then you can say hey I have a whole
bunch of different
you know what what a multi-core computer
is is it's basically a bunch of
computers
right so they're all independent
computers that can talk to each other
and they share memory and so now what
parallelized does it says okay run
multiple instances this on different
computers and now they can all work
together on Chrome right and so what
you're doing is you're saying keep going
out to the next level out and and as you
do that how do I take advantage of this
so tiling is a memory optimization right
it says okay let's make sure that we're
keeping the data close to the compute
part of the problem instead of sending
it all back and forth through memory
every every time I load a block and the
size of the block size is is all that's
how you get to the auto tune to make
sure it's optimized yeah well so all of
these The Details Matter so much to get
good performance this is another funny
thing about machine learning and high
performance Computing that is very
different than C compilers we all grew
up grew up with where you know if you
get a new version of GCC or a new
version of clang or something like that
you know maybe something will go one
percent faster
right and so compiler insurers will work
really really hard to get half a percent
out of your C code something like that
but when you're talking about an
accelerator or an AI application or
you're talking about these kinds of
algorithms now these are things people
used to write in Fortran for example
right
if you get it wrong it's not five
percent or one percent it could be 2X or
10x right if you think about it
um you really want to make use of the
full memory you have the cash for
example but if you use too much space it
doesn't fit in the cache now you're
going to be thrashing all the way back
out to main memory and these can be 2x
10x Major Performance differences and so
this is where getting these magic
numbers and these things right is really
actually quite important